[Music]
well there's a really common
misconception that technology is neutral
and it's up to us to just choose how to
use it and so we're sitting there and
we're scrolling and we find ourselves in
this kind of wormhole and then we say oh
man like I should really have more
self-control and that's partially true
but what we forget when we talk about it
that way is that there's a thousand
engineers and the other side of the
screen whose job it was was to get my
finger to do that the next time and
there's this whole playbook of
techniques that they use to get us to
keep using the software more so was
design always this manipulative you know
it wasn't always this way
in fact back in the 1970s in the early
80s at Xerox PARC when Steve Jobs first
went over and saw the graphical user
interface the way people talked about
computers and what computers were
supposed to be was a bicycle for our
minds that here we are you take a human
being and they have a certain set of
capacities and capabilities and then you
give them a bicycle and they can go to
all these new distances they're
empowered to go to these brand new
places and to do these new things to
have these new capacities and that's
always been the philosophy of people who
make technologies how do we create
bicycles for our minds to do and empower
us to feel and access more now when the
first iPhone was introduced it was also
the philosophy of these technology how
do we empower people to do something
more and what and in those days it
wasn't manipulative because there is no
competition for attention Photoshop
wasn't trying to maximize how much
attention it took from you it didn't
measure its success that way and the
internet overall had been in the very
beginning not designed to maximize
attention it was just a putting things
out there putting things out there
creating these message boards it wasn't
designed with this whole persuasive
psychology that emerged later what
happened is that the attention economy
in this race for attention got more and
more competitive and the more
competitive it got to get people's
attention on a fan news website the more
they need to add these design principles
these more manipulative design tactics
as ways of holding on to your attention
and so YouTube goes from being a more
neutral honest tool of just here's of
video to oh do you want to see these
other videos and oh do you want to
autoplay the next video and oh do you
want to you know you know here's some
notifications these products start to
look and feel more like media that's
about maximizing consumption and less
like bicycles for our minds and I think
that's such a subtle and important thing
to recognize is that more and more
technology is really not on our team to
help us spend our time the way we want
to it's more on the team of maximizing
how much time we spend on the screen
right now the only way to succeed in the
app store is by proving you're really
good at getting people attention and so
by making attention the currency of
success it forces all of you good
hearted good intentions people who make
apps or make media sites to do things
that they don't want to do just because
they have to get attention you have
meditation apps to have to send you all
these notifications and add streaks and
do all this gamey stuff just to get you
to use it the most as opposed to having
the phone itself recognized that there's
parts of your life where meditation
might want to be at the top of the list
for you because you're defining that and
so that meditation app could win for the
right winners and not for the wrong
reasons so we always worry about new
technologies when they first appear you
know we when people started bringing out
the newspapers on the subway people
worried oh my god people are going to
stop talking to each other on the subway
and then TV showed up the people worried
oh my god people are going to spend all
this time at home and the radio we
always worry and then somehow it seems
to turn out okay when we worry when our
art you know back in the 1970s people
were at home on the telephone and
calling each other all the time we
thought oh the kids these days what are
they doing to their minds right so now
it's tempting to say well now the kids
these days they're on snapchat and
therefore we survive all those other
technology transitions nothing really
bad happened so maybe it's all okay this
is just kids being kids in a new way
and I want to talk about why that's not
not true and why this is different
what's different is that let's say let's
take that telephone example in the 1970s
if
someone picked up a telephone to go call
their friend and they spent time
gossiping on the telephone we could do
that that's fine but the telephone
wasn't updated every day with new
manipulative design principles to be
better and better at seducing you into
calling your friends so it's different
with snapchat is that there was a
thousand engineers every single day who
work on the product to actually find new
ways not just to get you to use it but
to kind of tag you both on the shoulder
and try to get you into an arrest a
prosthetic relationship where you owe
someone else a response in fact they
have a feature called in snapchat called
snap streaks and snap streaks count the
number of days in a row you've sent a
message back and forth with someone so
if I've have a best friend and we've
been chatting every day for a hundred
days I see a little fireball and the
number 100 next to it and what that does
is they've just created something now I
don't want to lose because I have a
streak going I've got a hundred days and
now if I don't send them a message
tomorrow I'm going to lose the whole
thing and when you're a kid actually
this has a really big impact on you I'm
not making this up there's a woman named
Emily Weinstein at Harvard who studied
the effects of snapchat and snap streaks
on kids by accident and emerged in her
interviews and she found out that kids
when they go on vacation they have to
give their password to up to five other
friends to actually have them send
messages while they're gone
on vacation because they're so worried
about losing their snap streaks in fact
a lot of kids they wake up and they see
these 30 contacts with different streaks
and they have to just take pictures of
floors and feelings just to kind of get
through all these snap streaks they
don't lose any of them so we have to ask
when snapchat is designing a feature
like snap streaks are they doing that
because they most want to help kids
empower them to live their lives or are
they doing that because it's really good
at getting their attention and when
we're parents and we see kids using it
this way we have to recognize there's
something very different going on here
this was not true in the 1970s when we
had a neutral telephone that we would
choose to use when we wanted to use it
there are now a thousand people behind
our new telephone which is say snapchat
that's being designed and updated every
day to be more compelling at addicting
and holding onto people
tension and it's not good for us I mean
I think we can all feel it we become
more and more on the treadmill to the
number of likes or or feedback we get
basically from social media and start
tying our own approval our own
self-worth to how much attention we get
from other people I mean even for me I
noticed that you know if I post
something it does affect me whether or
not I have a lot of likes or a few likes
and it's hard to really if you think
about it get to the felt sense of my
self-worth is completely independent of
that that's a subtle thing to hold and
and developmentally a children are more
vulnerable to their self worth being
externalized like this and the problem
is that you know there's always been as
well ways of externalizing our
self-worth in terms of how much money we
have in our bank account or in terms of
how many friends we have but now the
external is a ssin of our self-worth is
controlled by a handful of companies
whose goals are different than our goals
they're not evil companies they just
have the different goal of maximizing
attention and our goals are not that but
the problem is that their goals become
our goal this is what's actually is so
dangerous is that their goals of
engaging us the most by having us care
about likes become our goals we actually
wake up in the morning as sovereign
human beings and we start caring about
the number of likes we got as if that's
our goal in life that becomes our goal
and it's as if we've been infected as if
we've you know they drilled a hole in
the back of our head and now they've
injected the virus and now we walk
around searching for feedback using
social media and they won if that
happens and again it's not because
they're evil but they're in a different
game they're trying to maximize
attention but we have to ask a much
deeper question which is what do we want
in our lives and what is our self-worth
actually tied to and maybe it's being
virtuous or being a good friend or being
you know caring about what matters or
living by our values there's a whole
bunch of things that we could define for
ourselves and I think the left people
have defined their own
values the more vulnerable they are to
someone else coming in and giving them
their values and to sticks that we're
going to need to talk about different
kinds of metrics different ways of
measuring success and monetizing success
so instead of making more money the more
time we get we instead make more money
the more we've helped you in your life
[Music]